- So Kimberly, so on the new song,
someone told me that you
guys used mouth trumpets
on this song, and I can actually hear it,
especially at the end,
one of the last ones.
So care to explain how that happened
and was wine, beer, or whiskey involved?
(laughing)
- Absolutely.
(mouth trumpet noise)
- I think Jimmy has
the best mouth trumpet.
(mouth trumpet noise)
- I can't do that.
Did y'all all do it?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
Some trumpets are better than others.
- We considered leaving it like that.
- You can hear the mouth
trumpet at the end though.
At the very end
that's the best part,
and it's like, I want to go to that party
where at the end I feel
like I'm so awesome
I can play a trumpet with my mouth.
- Well, we were gonna
keep the mouth trumpets,
but we decided to add
Jacob from The Brummies,
a great little band,
and he played trumpet on the record,
so we were like, we gotta have both.
- I love it.
The vibe is so cool, guys,
like how the song starts out.
It's like, where is this going?
Like, and then it, how it ends.
It literally is so cool.
That's what I love about your,
you're so adventurous and you
play with different genres,
and it's just really,
it's really, really
cool to be a fan of you
and how y'all are unafraid of that.
It's nice to go on the ride with y'all.